hang on a second hang on a second I am
really dizzy Winona Judd had the crowd
worried during a concert in Dayton Ohio
stopping the show when she felt a dizzy
mid-song life is so full of so many
things and feelings and people and
for me it's all happening every single
night in those two hours now the singer
is sharing an update assuring fans all
is well I'm doing really well because
I'm doing my work it all went down on
Friday when Winona halted her
performance and asked for some help on
stage hang on a second hang on a second
I am really dizzy and somebody come up
here please
yeah I'm really dehydrated and I'm I'm
having a hard time so hang on a second
[Applause]
hang on
I'm just really dizzy and this has never
happened before a crew member rushed to
Winona's side and offered her a stool to
sit on if I faint just take a lot of
pictures okay
Mama He's Crazy
crazy
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going down babe
[Music]
the country singer rallied and finished
the show and after the performance she
assured fans on Instagram she's okay
thinking Little Big Town and Martina
McBride who she was performing with for
their support during the whole ordeal
all is well y'all Little Big Town and
Martina McBride you are such a blessing
to me thank you for holding me up
literally and figuratively the
performance was a stop on the judge the
final tour which kicked off in October
and will run through February I'm in the
middle of
feeling both
like the pressure's off
and yet this is it because once this is
done this is a chapter closed
so you kind of have this feeling of
we shall never pass this way again last
year the singer canceled a New Year's
Eve performance leading many to worry
that she was working too hard at the
time Winona addressed the concern on
Instagram writing in part that she was
working on her mental physical and
spiritual well-being and added that
she's working really hard at self-care
which is not selfish it's sacred quote
I'm okay and the last thing I'll say is
can't keep a good woman down for too
long I'm real
and I'm not perfect I'm perfectly
imperfect and I struggle
and I think when I struggle I say it on
stage I say
I'm struggling right now and sometimes I
have to sit down because I'm so
overwhelmed and the love coming at me
knocks me over literally I've had to sit
down because it's too much Winona has
continued the tour in honor of her
mother and bandmate Naomi Judd who died
by Suicide back in April and she opened
up to E.T about paying tribute to her
mom's Legacy the chapter with Mother
leaving it's painful but the music
the music is what remains just like love
the music that comes from such a deep
place in here
comes out through here and into the
audience and they just feel it